so so hold on this one's great this
one's great you guys are gonna love this
what do you think
uh uh rachel maddow had to say about
vladimir putin's comments
on january 6 ashley rabbit so let me
just do a quick context here
for those that missed the first part of
this of the show vladimir putin came out
and said you guys basically you
criticized me over alexi navalny in the
opposition protests
but look what you're doing to trump
supporters and the january six riot look
what you're doing people
and then he actually asked did you order
the assassination of ashley
of the woman who was shot by that police
officer he comes out really critical
now what do you think rachel maddow of
msnbc
said that that putin was doing she
combusted
she exploded yes she burst in no way
dude did she
she reached her purest form this is
exactly what she lives for vladimir
putin coming out
and defending trump supporters her eyes
started glowing
and she started emitting a powerful aura
she levitated from her chair
msnbc putin's russia adopts
republican talking points on january 6
riot
on january 6 far-right republicans have
a political ally once again
in vladimir putin who's only too pleased
to amplify their talking points
russia's back i was worried for a minute
i was sad i missed i missed talking
about you know all the russian nonsense
uh thank you rachel maddow you know i
bet she cried
when putin came out and said this said
this because when the mueller report
came out
saying that you know donald trump did
not collude and there was no evidence
she was nearly crying mm-hmm
and there's that really funny video the
woman's filming and she's like shaking
with laughter like she's crying
she's crying and rachel meadow's like
there's nothing
here she like she didn't really start
crying
but you know she was like holding back
you would think these people would have
some kind of like
wake up to reality you would think these
people after crying on national
television after lying to the american
people for four
years telling us russian collusion trump
is russia russia's involved in our
politics russia
still you know changed the elections you
would think after that realization after
that huge pie
in her face still preferably there in my
opinion
just an absolute disgrace for four years
you would think
they would just stop it but they double
down it's intentional that's why yeah
obviously i mean i think some kid with a
vpn might have flipped it on
and and worked out of a russian ip i
mean there's no way
there's no that that conversation's
never even entered rachel i've never
heard rachel maddow or anybody like talk
like postulate is it possible that some
corporation is working with a russian ip
it could be anybody i've never heard
them mention of vpn as a possible
answer to why we think it's from russia
and and we also have
the the world economic forum talked
about
we we want to get away from capitalism
we want to get away from meat
we want to uh what was the other one you
own nothing oh get away from oil
and then we had a lockdown that shut
down the economy for a year
and then we had what else we had the
pipeline
that got hacked the meat the meat hack
and then the meat hack those are all
those are
all beneficial for the wbf very
interestingly the world economic forum
is doing
cyber polygon they're digital online war
games
they're going to be doing it in a few
days from now they did it last year
they're going to do it again this year
and they're literally practicing and
drilling
big severe war games that damage the
infrastructure of countries so they've
been
they've been they've been like exactly
drilling this last year they're doing it
again this year with a whole bunch of
corporations a whole bunch of
governments involved in this
larger uh cyber polygon uh world
economic forum project that they're
pushing to the to the lexicon again
world economic forum huge entity
we got it right here i just want to
issue one clarification too the rachel
maddow comments were about
last week putin said something very
similar that the people who stormed the
capital were
there with political demands basically
the same thing he said recently but not
the ashley babbitt part
but yes we also have the worldeconomic
forum.org
newsguard certified so you know it's
legit cyberpolygon and they say
it's a unique cybersecurity event that
combines the world's largest technical
training exercise for corporate teams
and an online conference featuring
senior officials from international
organizations and leading corporations
they're saying it's an online conference
obviously it's a cyber security event so
there's going to be an aspect of
you know obviously cyber security wasn't
there something that uh uh
what was it cloud schwab said about a
digital kind of pandemic where we're
getting these cyber attacks and the
damage that it can wreak
he said that too yeah he warned about it
i i don't i don't remember the details
but
he was bringing it up in the same uh you
know lane as the pandemic so
yeah a lot of people are bringing up
event 201 i'm not saying you know
correlation is causation
and even with this hacking stuff it
could be russia
it could be china it could be israel
israel also hacked
american systems and spied on american
politicians and spied on american
infrastructure stole
american secrets sold it to china not a
lot of people know this the online
digital
ship yeah yeah the online digital cyber
space
is is a crazy world where even allies
hack other allies
now with these nsa spying tools
available for
everyone that were paid for by your tax
dollars these ransom attacks
there's a lot more of them that we don't
even know about it because there's a lot
there's no news reports about them and
then i think they're happening a lot
more than we even
know because just like you know
there's you know uh sporting events
where they make sure that they don't
uh film people who run on on the stage
you know i think this is also a similar
thing that's unfolding right now and it
should be questioned especially with
the latest fbi retrieval of these
bitcoins because
that story also doesn't add up because
these sophisticated hackers somehow
put their bitcoin that they got on a
wallet that they didn't have the private
keys on
that the fbi was just able to get a
subpoena from the servers and you put it
on a hot wallet
and you put a hot wallet where you don't
know the price that was weird that's
weird that's super weird and the story
doesn't add up
the story does not add up about these
cyber attacks and online
there could be false flags it could be
other countries it could be
iran it could be kenya it could be you
know who who knows it could be private
there could be corporate interest i'm
going to say something
not to overly speculate but i just want
to point out there was
a colonial pipeline hack shut down
largest pipeline in the country we had
the jbs meat hack
shut down i think a fifth of the beef
production in this country
we had a chemical plant just burst into
flames blow up in illinois
don't know that's related to anything
but we had another oil refineries in
iran
blows up i remember when donald trump
was flying some planes to iran he was
gonna wipe he was gonna do an airstrike
i think on the coast
take out some of their surface-to-air
stuff or whatever and then all of a
sudden they were treated
and then trump said he asked he you know
he asked his advisors how many people
would die over this and they said it was
gonna be like a hundred is that it's not
worth taking that many lives over what's
happening
the interesting thing is you know what
happened in between
that airstrike from when the planes
launched when they turn around
i think it could be wrong so faction on
this one because it's been a while there
was a a plant in philadelphia some kind
of like refinery that that went up in
flames
now i asked my cyber security friends if
they thought that maybe iran issued a a
like it's called a
industrial control system attack and i
see i think it's called ics
uh attacked us and then trump panicked
they said no no no no that's probably
not the case probably not the case
so okay okay all right i'll air on that
on that side but i will point out
if there was major cyber attacks
happening do you think they're gonna
come out and just be like oh by the way
you know iran just
blew up one of our facilities of course
they wouldn't why they don't
they want war when they want war not
when they don't want war so they
the the united states government doesn't
want to be forced into a war if they
came out and said
we've actually were attacked in this
regard the american people would be
livid
they'll control the flow of information
and the moment they actually do want to
launch an assault
it'll be all over every single tv didn't
we start this with stuxnet with the
nuclear refinement i don't think started
it well
i don't know i don't know who started it
it's an ongoing it's been happening for
a very long time and the online
cyberspace is congested with wars upon
wars allies spying on allies allies
attacking allies it's such a complicated
space so just to
blame everything on russia is also kind
of a little bit worrying
especially with the latest troop
movements that happened uh just a few
weeks ago
so so seeing the mainstream media fully
point the picture at russia during these
events
is is a little bit worrying to be honest
with you because as you said if they
want
to prop up a war that they could easily
prop up a war and right now they're
saying russia russia russia
and that brings me back to the main
point rachel maddow coming out
with a smile on her face and a sparkle
in her eye
oh vladimir putin's defending trump
thank you
that's what she needed she needs to
justify she needs to prove to her
audience that there wasn't four years
wasted
and with the scariest thing to me people
who believe it
the people who have been lied to over
and over again for
years still come crawling back for more
begging please lie to me i have
relatives that are that way it's it's
mind-blowing i
i don't understand how after five years
of getting promised
these smoking guns and getting nothing
getting no source material whatsoever
and we were talking about with the the
hacks and things that are happening even
if you get reporting on it
you don't get any sourced information
like they will say
i mean the source will be a high-ranking
pentagon official that doesn't [ __ ]
i'm sorry but that's not good enough for
me
not in 2021 i'm gonna need a little bit
more than that there's nothing more
trustworthy than an anonymous source
from the military-industrial complex and
intelligence agencies yes i wouldn't
believe it
uh but but again this is this is big i
mean
we're heading into a time that's that's
extremely perplexing extremely worrying
because on the online digital space you
could do anything
and the realm of possibility is far and
wide so
uh and it's and it's impossible to get
any real concrete evidence
i wouldn't be surprised if mutually
assured destruction existed in the cyber
realm now too like we have
obviously nukes ready to go if anybody
but like if you invade here we're
shutting down all your oil refineries
the chinese could do it to the united
states united states could do the
chinese the russians could do it to the
indians the indians could do the united
states
so we're all like in this i don't that
weird mexican standoff term like has
nothing to do with mexico anymore it's
like we're all
ready to move and not no one wants to
take the first step because their
infrastructure is going to get torched
but with cyber security it's different
with uh with nukes
if like so mexican stanford is
unfamiliar it's like there's three
people
and they're each pointing guns at each
other and no one wants to shoot first
because then they'll get shot
so whoever shoots first loses the first
guy gets shot goes down
then the guy who shoots get shot by the
other guy the last guy standing so
nobody wants to move when you get a
bunch of countries with nukes
sure they could theoretically be like
okay fire our nukes at all of the major
capitals
maybe they don't have enough i think
russia might and the u.s might china
probably doesn't have enough nukes but
they've got it they've got a decent
amount india and pakistan i think
avenues
so it's it's still a mexican standoff
the us is like if we fire our nukes at
russia
we'll get hit from some other countries
with cybers with cyber attacks
we could have infected every industrial
control system across the planet
and with a press of a button shut it all
down so it's not necessarily
however i'd be willing to bet that their
nukes of other countries
they've got manual operation so in the
event the u.s says
shut down all of the industrial controls
for as many countries as possible
the nukes will start flying and we don't
have the ability to take them all out
there's a bunch of
there's been a bunch of uh efforts to be
able to stop nuclear weapons like it's
one one was called the strategic defense
initiative i think the sdi system
and that was trying to fire rockets and
blow up icy icbms in mid-air
kind of like how the iron dome works in
israel and then we i think we have the
thaad in south korea but it's not enough
one nuke gets through and you take out a
city especially if it explodes in the
air i mean if a nuke goes up
in the air man that is rough on the
environment they do explode in the air
they don't land
yeah nukes don't blow up they don't hit
the ground and blow up that would limit
the blast radius
nukes go right above the target and then
blow up blanketing down
wow dude the people who build these
these these weapons merchants of death
who knew how to maximize
like there's when they do something
gravity bombs that's when a plane drops
a bomb
so the first bombs that were ever used
the only ones were called gravity bombs
we flew a plane over we dropped it you
we also got icbms they they they did the
math
they know exactly the maneuver you have
to do it's like a it's like a 90 degree
or like a 270 degree turn or something
to maximize the escape
so the shock wave of the nuclear bomb
doesn't hit the plane
they calculate the stuff to a t to
maximize death that's horrifying that is
scary
i live on the water in san diego and i i
saw
a missile launch and i thought it was
russia nuking us because i'm right by
pendleton camp pendleton
and i went and i dove in my tub because
i'm sick i'm such a little girl
but but i found out later that it was uh
spacex i was like
elon could you give me a heads up i
almost my pants your mind went to russia
first
i swear to god it did wow do you think
that's because of media manipulation
yeah this was three years ago so of
course yeah
well the fear-mongering is very strong
and and you know the stuff you bring
about
you know some people would say it's
far-fetched some people wouldn't say but
but this is the stuff that we
know about there's other weapons systems
that we don't even know about that
vladimir putin even hinted at previously
before
where he was talking about tsunami
weapons uh utilizing oceans in order to
take out you know coastal infrastructure
of major countries
so you know the levels of sophistication
when you describe merchants of debts
it doesn't just happen with nuclear
weapons it also happens
in laboratories with people creating bio
weapons
in order to infect and hurt and kill
people as much as they can which we
know a lot of countries have been
working and developing on viruses that
do affect people on their different
genomes on their
different genetic structures thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you